he came up with one of the most famous
plays in the history of the super bowl
100-yard pick six of my buddy kurt
warner that we can't replay more than
enough times on game day morning in his
face five-time pro bowler two super bowl
wins and the only undrafted player to
ever win the defensive player of the
year award as he did in 2008
the subject of tonight's football life
on nfl network at 9 00 p.m eastern time
james harrison here on the rich eisen
show how are you james
i'm doing good man thank you for having
me i think i just did your entire
football life so i don't know if we even
need to chat but i think that just might
have summed that one up
hey congrats have you seen the uh the
the show yet have you seen the piece
yeah james yeah yeah i've seen i've i've
seen uh i've seen it in uh you know it's
something you're not going to want to
miss you get to get a little
glimpse into james harrison you know off
the football field so how did you better
understand how did you get your first
break like what did what was your first
big break james
um to be honest with you it was really
probably clark hagen's breaking his hand
and
in pittsburgh to open up your spot yeah
okay yeah that's what got me back into
because i've been cutting you know like
four times before that did nfl europe
all of that
and um you know i'm just sitting around
waiting and then you know i made my mind
up that you know if i don't get picked
up this year then you know that's gonna
be a good regular job like everybody
else
and clark higgins you know he breaks his
hand and they pick me up and
the rest is history some speaking what
was it like to be a member of the rhine
fire james harrison after you
you fought your way to the steelers and
then wound up with the rhine fire um
what what before you know the ravens
they cut you what was that like for you
what happened is uh i went to the rhine
fire i was allocated by the ravens so my
first year i was on practice squad with
the steelers i made the active roster
the next year they cut me the next day
i sat around
nothing happened they picked me back up
cut me again
then the ravens picked me up in the off
season
and allocated me to go to nfl europe
where you do the developmental so i went
over there
and after i got back from that the
ravens released me
in a week because they needed to pick up
a titan
the crazy thing is the tight end that
they picked up was daniel wilcox i
played with him in nfl europe
so as i'm driving home
you know because they didn't release me
i get called in i was just like you know
hey it's a numbers thing we need a tight
end like all right you know whatever so
i'm driving home and my phone rings it's
daniel
yo bro i got great news i'm like yo
what's going on like uh i'm gonna be
there with you at the ravens man they
just picked me up i'm like oh i'm like
well at least i know what tight end they
picked up who they you know released me
for it's like when you talk about that
they just released me to pick you up
wow
no kidding yeah what a story that is
yeah daniel was there for about four
five six years something like that
so then uh you get the big break because
um right so after they released me
that's when clark pagans uh breaks his
hand about a week before training camp
and really what it came down to us they
needed an extra body
you know because the numbers threw the
numbers off when he couldn't you know he
couldn't prepare practice doing anything
so when i got there you know i wasn't
thinking about making the students
roster i was thinking about i need to go
out here and put out the best tape that
i can
and hopefully one of these 31 other
teams to pick me up well that 2004
season was pretty big because they went
ahead and they drafted a kid you know
out of miami of ohio so they got a kent
state linebacker and a miami of ohio
quarterback and look out from there on
out no i was in 2002. i was undrafted in
2002 right there two years before then
right and then and then after the rhine
fires when you showed back up in
pittsburgh you know four right right yes
what was that season like
when ben showed up because i remember
that was our first full season we
covered at nfl network james and the
conversation was you know current now
freshly minted hall of famer allen
fanuca is like yeah i don't know why
we're you know our whole season's in the
in the hands of a rookie
and
you know i think there was a hurricane
in miami and you guys all got together
and the rest is kind of history in that
season james
i was you know i was young into it so i
don't know exactly what they had going
on there but i mean you really had a
defensively built football teams back
then that had a good offensive line and
they ran the ball so it was it was a
good defense and they ran the ball and
you know uh basically at that point in
time ben was just managing you know you
had you had times where you know his run
run play action and you know he'd hit
him for you know huge starts you know
huge numbers he would only pass maybe
you know 20 25 times a game and you know
he'd complete 60 75 of those because
they were so heavy into trying to stop
that run because of how the offense was
sorted that it gave him those great
opportunities for play action passes
james harrison here on the rich eisen
show uh on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line right here on on a busy friday uh
and we'll get to the the current day uh
in a minute but i do want to stroll down
memory lane for your career so that uh
that
super bowl
where
you're
trying to keep the cardinals out of the
end zone hold him to just three before
half time
what happened on that play where you
picked off curt and did you think at
some point oh my god i'm still running
during that
interception well james
it was a max blitz i was supposed to be
blessing of course everybody knows the
story and
i i don't list but i make sure i step at
the tackle so that norris kenneth can
get through on that inside and make sure
he gets pressure on the quarterback so
he can't hold the ball it's only 18
seconds left when playing for the quick
slant in because that's the closest
thing to me that's the you know close
thing i can affect and as i you know do
that and i drop
you know he just throws the ball to me
i'm looking like i'm looking like he's
about to throw the ball and he actually
throws it to me as soon as i get the
ball
i'm like i'm gone but i'm fighting with
the same town for like for like 30
seconds or something right and as i look
up i'm like holy hell to see a red
jersey i'm like i ain't gonna make it so
we make it through the little first
little cluster i jump over a guy with me
block the guy jump over him
and at that point i feel like i've been
running for like the last two minutes or
something right
so i'm like the clock is out of time i
have to make it there's no way i cannot
make it all this would be from nothing
so you know it was it was uh emotions of
oh i'm going as soon as i caught the
ball and then like oh hell i'm not gonna
make it and then like you said it was uh
i gotta make it
and then you
made it
and um we made it
we
well i mean larry fitzgerald was trying
to track you down i mean he was just uh
he was he was right there as well and
so um
how
how did that play change your career do
you think at all at you know you
anything different because of that james
uh i got a better contract than next
year
that's a football life right there okay
so that's right that helped you get
the bank that you were looking for
that's what you're saying yeah it helped
help me secure secure my future and the
future of my children okay and then uh
obviously your your
your tenure with the steelers comes to
an end you wound up in
new england how how different were those
teams what you and and and your
and i guess the locker rooms culture
how different were they because you know
we're
we're
you're you're trying to beat the heck
out of them for over a decade and then
you join them
um
how eye-opening was that for you can you
walk me through any differences that you
saw
james uh you know the the big thing in
new england it's just you know
especially for guys who say they didn't
like it there it was horrible or that
it's for people who aren't used to
discipline or used to regiment or used
to be in to happen to follow the rules
of every you know every other person and
like i said i enjoyed my time there i
didn't have a problem with it and it's
the patriot way because they win
and
if
you have to
do your job and so-called not have fun
at it
and win i'm i don't have a problem with
that right
so
i don't yeah like i said i enjoyed
myself i had no issues with it even when
you know i got there i still had a
regimen of you know body workers that i
had come in they made sure
that you know if it was something that
they needed to do to accommodate room
space whatever it is so that my people
could be there to work on me they did
that
you know so
i like that i have no qualms or you know
issues with how they operated or
did anything
so you james harrison when you joined
the new england patriots you told
belichick
or somebody that hey i've got
x number of people that are going to
personally help me with my training and
my physical regimen and they made the
space for those people within their
construct that happen
no no not within their construct like
say i needed like say we have like uh
like like super bowl with super yes and
you have to get obviously hotel rooms so
if that space i couldn't get it they
would help get that so that i made sure
i could have
the people i need there so that i'm able
to function and be able to play at
opposing levels so it's not like no you
can't just come to the facility get your
own room and have you know nothing like
that yeah that's what i was going to ask
because because with brady return rude
brady returning in new england next week
i mean that's going to be front and
center james quite a bit about the tb12
and his trainer and
how much accommodation that belichick
and the rest of the organization was
willing to make i mean you had a front
row seat for all of that in 2017
it seemed like to be totally honest with
you uh yeah i mean he was there but i
never saw him
his train brady's trainer you mean
yeah
i mean they had their own area that they
would go to her office i guess and
that's where he would go get his
treatment you know you know i believe he
even allowed other guys who wanted to
you know get treatment to use to use him
and
so on and so forth but
like i said it was not like oh don't go
in this area because tom and they're
training no it was nothing like that
right
you free flow like a regular locker room
and did you see anything between you
know brady and belichick that made you
think that this is somewhat
you know dysfunctional in a way because
again this is the sort of stuff that we
might be hearing towards the end yeah
it's it's
that is all
like manifest like that's just stuff
that the media was making up i felt it i
look for it believe me nothing
i'm like okay the patriots have their
own stuff going on like other teams do
and i get there and it's like wow i see
why it's
us versus everybody and that's the
mentality that he uses because
from what i've seen and what i've you
know
read
it is night and day from what is being
told and what is actually happening
james harris that's why they bond
together and stick together and pride
the way they do james harrison here on
the rich eisen show his football life is
tonight at 9 eastern time on nfl network
everyone should check out the
fascinating ascension of james harrison
from undrafted player to super bowl
champion and five-time pro bowler and so
on and so forth what about the current
day for the steelers do you think that
big ben is um
having his diminishing returns right
here in front of us that tomlin and the
rest of this team is in trouble for the
year right now despite being just one
and one it's still early i wonder what
your thoughts on the the steelers after
they lose to the raiders and they're
getting set for the bengals and big
ben's already banged up and it's week
three what are your thoughts
my thing is this i think they need to uh
figure out what their identity is going
to be on offense
i don't know what that is or what that
process is or how you do that
they need to get healthy of course
and i think it's going to be a defensive
team it's going to be the the spinners
of old that you know have these
tremendous defenses that you try and
keep the game
low scoring and at some point in time on
the defense you need to either score
give scoring position get turnovers do
something that's going to affect that
game and keep it close enough so that
when that opportunity comes and you take
advantage of that opportunity it will
be something that is going to
tremendously affect the game and help
you win the game
and uh i think you're referring to like
naji harris right because i i think they
need to establish that kid and run it
and make sure that that because that's
when you guys back in the day were the
best you know when the bus is running
over brian urlacher and the snow right
when you start when you start running
the ball effectively
and now instead of them having seven
they need eight in the box and possibly
nine that's when that play action run
that opens up
for that opportunity to get those passes
get those long uh you know passes down
the field and now
you get them back to where they're
switching back all right let me drop one
or two out of the box and then start
running the ball again
i mean i don't know if the offensive
line is uh it's dope well not no i know
it's not built like it was back then but
they need to find some way to shore up
the offensive line so that they can have
opportunities like that
james harrison i appreciate the call um
what do you want people to know about
tonight's show so we let's get them all
watching it's going to be the best
football life that you ever watched in
in your life um
you know to be honest with you they
probably could have made this a three
part you know did three different times
because there's so much they're trying
to convince into into just one hour they
could have did three hours easily okay
but um i think they're going to find out
things about me that uh they didn't know
and the perception of me is going to
change for them because they'll get a
glimpse on the inside so to speak well
i'd love to get you back as the season
goes along your your thoughts on the
season and certainly because one of the
members of my team uh is out today uh
he's an audio executive who doesn't
really work out all that much but when
he referred to uh saying that he could
plank 225 he meant two plates of 25
pounds james
and i thought
and i think i need i'm good listen it's
better than no plates that is true um
but uh the plates are somewhere no the
plates he usually has is full of ziti
and i think i need you to uh uh let him
know
um what what two plates of
you know
you know 25 it's really you know 225 and
i think i need you to help them do the
math next time
okay james
we'll get you back and do that all right
you take care james harrison is football
live tonight friday nine eastern time on
nfl network
thanks again james i really appreciate
it we'll get you back i'd love to chat
with you welcome thank you thanks james
take care hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here